so this is going to be an unusual papers
we love talk I'm going to discuss a
bunch of different papers in relatively
light detail but with Rich historical
context I will post a transcript and
mini site for this talk with links to
all the papers and many others that
serve as supporting material so last
year I gave a talk of strange Loop where
I said everyone is programming wrong
this this upset some people and I
thought I'd make a more modest claim
today everyone is doing mathematics
wrong so
so we'll need some background to make
sense of what follows and I'm going to
start with a very easy question what is
mathematics and where does it come from
famously no one has ever struggled with
this
one so there are many lenses for this
question I'm going to supply one to
serve for the duration of this talk I I
think we both discover and invent
mathematics as we go and the part of
what we discover is the nature of our
own evolved capabilities and we'll start
with geometry which is in my opinion the
basis for everything else we have Okay
so
from this little guy here uh upper right
quadrant for you uh we have a half
billion year old bug likee Cambrian
swimmer and then we have bug eating
early mammals and then we have a buge
eating prian I mean giving our family
tree it's no surprise that our software
is full of bugs but we have something
else in common which is that we all
Survive by moving through 3D space and
to move through space you need to be
able to plan based on what you're
sensing which requires you to emulate
the world to make predictions about
future States so this is Simone biles
one of the greatest gymnasts ever to
compete she's showing truly Elite human
spatial and thus geometric ability and
my contention is that everything we do
in technical mathematics the kind we use
in engineering and most physics comes
from the same evolved capacities allow
her to plan and execute that elaborate
series of translations and rotations and
our ability to turn those physical gifts
inward is what has given us sculpture
and perspective drawing as well as
mathematical geometry and our ability to
reason about objects in space LED
naturally to our number sense now many
animals have been shown to count objects
and work with sequences and there seems
to be a natural development of pattern
matching and interacting with objects in
the world most of you know that pigeons
and rats can learn to press a lever a
certain number of times to get a treat
what you might be more surprised to
learn is that red Forest ants can count
to around 20 and communicate those
quantities to other ants and some
animals can apply short-term memory to
sequences better than most humans this
chimp is memorizing these numerical
sequences and tapping them out after
they're uded this is something at which
the average chimp outperforms the
average human this brings us to algebra
so while numb exists in some extent to
in most animals in geometric sense
probably exists in all complex life
forms algebra is more specifically human
it has biological roots in language and
deliberation so this is the first paper
I'll recommend today even though it has
nothing to do with computer science or
mathematics it's an especially good
followup to the research on bias that
you might have seen from kotan and tki
and things like thinking fast and slow
their claim and I I think they're right
is that as a group living species our
reason abilities Rose in the context of
deliberation which gave rise to
persuasion and the skeptical evaluation
of claims and this arms race between
these facilities reified cause and
effect reasoning into a conscious
reflective and linguistic process formal
logic and symbolic fluencies seem to be
Downstream of this and once we
translated the ability to communicate
via streams of words and symbols that is
to say into art and writing we were able
to develop notation at which point we
move from biology to culture in our
story here today and one of the most
successful cultural artifacts of all
time is math notation so we might ask
what's it for it's both for
communication and for thinking you know
the Simplicity and Clarity of a good
notation not only allows us to serialize
our understanding and transmit it to
other human beings it also becomes an
engine for our own thinking in the
context of physics and Engineering we
really want that notation to speak as
directly as possible to our inner
gymnast so that we can bring our deepest
evolved powers to bear on whatever
problem we're solving as Bertrand
Russell puts it here a good notation can
be a teacher unto itself you bounce your
ideas off of formalism that guide you to
a deeper understanding that said if he
were alive today I think he'd go further
in Champion Machine readable notation
that is to say programming language
anybody here who has both worked with an
Al through an algebraic problem on paper
and also used an interactive programming
system like for example Mathematica will
be able to attest the power of the
ladder for improving understanding so
I'm going to look at mathematics uh
mathematical dotation through a
programming language lens throughout the
day and this is an eccentric way of
doing this and I'm going to
anachronistically project back ideas
that didn't exist at the Times these
things were invented uh and I I'm doing
this both because this is a an audience
of mostly programmers with varying
levels of mathematical ability but also
so because I think we do need to apply
what we've learned from programming
languages in the 20th century so this
notation is really it's it's one of our
best tools for thought and I don't have
time to make the full argument for this
and for the need to move to machine
readable uh notations here today but I
will recommend strongly this paper by
susman and wisdom which discusses the
work they did creating a scheme based
curriculum for classical mechanics if
You' prefer it in talk Mo uh talk form
check out susman's programming for the
expression of ideas and Sam Richie talks
about Emy a closure report of susman
system which I I hope you all saw at his
talk earlier today at this conference so
what do we really want for this kind of
notation well we want a small number of
orthal Primitives it's going to be
purely functional because mathematics is
it'll have recursive definitions and
it'll be lightly objectoriented and I
mean that in the sense that it will have
generic dispatch of some set of
operations over a family of mathematical
objects so let's build a protocol for
arithmetic in the same order our
cultural ancestors did starting with the
natural numbers the non- negative
integers now I say non- negative but a
fun fact about the natural numbers that
there's still to this day no agreement
as to whether they include
zero these are the numbers we use in
informal or folk mathematics the ones we
share with those Forest ANS we saw
earlier they're very tangible and
intuitive you can do the first three
operations on this slide with any kind
of object in the in the natural world
division is a bit weird right you either
have to accept that the operation
returns a tuple of quotient and
remainder which initially feels like a
type error or you need to invent
fractions at which point you have
rational numbers but only the positive
ones so this would be whole numbers and
vulgar fractions right now these are
usually uh presented after the integers
for set theoretical reasons but we're
working today in the order in which
these are normally discovered rather
than the order in which they're taught
so then we have a protocol that looks
like this right we've got these four
operations we've got these types now the
first people we see using this protocol
are in ancient Mesopotamia these objects
you see here are almost 6,000 years old
the thing on the top is called a bulla
which is a kind of spherical clay
envelope and the smaller things below
are stylized representations of trade
goods let's say the middle row are Quant
tokens yeah so I might put three of them
in a bullet and then seal it with a
amazing cryptographically secure
cylinder seal of people walking to the
left as you see here and then later you
could drop by my bakery and collect your
pastries so this is tangible Computing
in an extreme sense right so over time
they switched using tokens to make
impressions in clay tablets so you could
just push the goat token down five times
and say well that's five goats and then
they move to drawing you know directly
on the clay and making tally marks which
gets a little better better fun things
to note about this piece of History
sculpture preceded writing our first
forms of writing were about numbers and
accounting and credit long precede the
invention of money anyway these were
very intelligent people so they quickly
invented a more abstract numerical
notation that looked like this now it's
base 60 unlike our base 10 numbers but
they had a true place value system like
we do not like Roman numerals and 60 is
actually a boss way to do this because
it has all these factors so if you're
living in a world where you're doing
everything with fractions as they were
it's amazing to be able to factor all of
your numbers they even did their uh
their division by multiplication of
fractions so instead of dividing
something by two they would multiply it
by 1/2 or as as we put it these days
multiplication by reciprocals and to
make that fast they had big pre-computed
tablets of reciprocals squares cubes uh
roots and everything else which we see
Engineers doing in our culture as late
as the 20th century right up until there
were computers so you might ask what did
they get up to with all these numbers so
I call this tablet a paper I love but
it's actually a 4,000 year old old
homework
assignment right so what's this person
doing this young scribe they're solving
a problem of area using using Pythagoras
Theorem which you'll note is named after
someone born 1500 years
later and the uniform writing in the
middle shows the square root of two to
six decimal places they were iteratively
approximating irrational numbers in
Babylon which is why God struck them
down actually
so so what were they doing like they
developed these tools for surveying
initially because they were calculating
the areas of parcels and fields which as
as an agrarian people you'd expect and
they were doing a lot of astronomy
because they had a moon-based calendar
the way everybody does a lunar calendar
and they needed to square it with the
solar on so they knew when to plant for
the seasons and all that but they went
way past what was reasonable for this
purpose everything was Surplus to
requirements it's pretty clear to me
reading these old tablets that the
scribal class was composed of the same
kind of curious weirdos who invent
everything everywhere in every culture
they solved quadratic and cubic
equations they worked worked with
exponential growth and interest rates
they even came up with a fourar analysis
to compute the ephemeris so they could
pick out where the plans would be in the
future this is approximately on par with
European mathematics 3500 years later so
you might wonder why weren't we on the
Moon by like a thousand BCE right you
know they were prosperous and they were
so close to inventing modern technical
mathematics to put in perspective we're
only about 600 years after European
mathematics reached the same point and
the answer as it so often is
yeah so their agric cultural technology
that allowed them to feed their big
cities and develop their sophisticated
culture was unsustainable the soil grew
depleted and salty over time reducing
crop yields and then there was an
interval of rapid and severe climate
change that led to famine and War any
resemblance to the current ERA is I'm
sure entirely coincidental and no cause
for
alarm anyway after around 1550 BC
there's a dramatic fallof of
mathematical tablets all you get are
things like this King telling that King
that he's going to go kill him if he
doesn't give him enough whatever and we
don't see very much mathematical
progress for about a thousand years this
was a long period of relative stagnation
The Good the highlights I can give is
the Greeks invented basic formal proofs
around 600 BC and a couple of people
came up with good ways to approximate
the area under a curve but otherwise not
much was happening and one of the
reasons for all of this stagnation was
that the Greeks really hated irrational
mbers although Babylonians and Egyptians
were okay with approximating the square
root of two the Greeks thought that they
were an Abomination if contemporary
counsel to be believed people were
murdered in ancient Greece for talking
about these numbers which violated
closely held philosophical ideas
ultimately they wanted Mass to be like
the counting with tokens thing that we
saw earlier which I contend held them
back for quite some time so for the next
thousand or so years after that various
cultures took turns shepherding the
torch of the surviving wisdom of the
Ancients the Greeks the Persians Indian
mathematicians the House of Wisdom in
Baghdad Brahma Gupta and Alaris or as
important to what we have today as Dart
and gaus but in the interest of time
we're just going to skip forward to
Italy in the 1800s so by that time our
protocol has grown to include a few more
types right we have most of the numeric
types that we recognize but we still
have the same four basic methods over it
and uh some of these numbers are a bit
weird like the irrationals are odd but
if you squinted them long enough you can
kind of pretend they're at least the
same kind of thing as the natural
numbers because we're interested in
Geometry let's just take a quick look at
these numbers through a spatial or a
geometric lens right so spatially this
number line is a bit strange right we
don't we're not taught that it's weird
but it is weird because we have an
infinite line but somehow it also has an
end at zero and it's a singularity
beneath which subtraction fails so you
know to to really get somewhere you need
negative numbers and as you might
imagine people hated negative numbers
too they really despise them uh and this
is mainly because it's not intuitively
obvious that you can have minus three
goats right it just doesn't make
sense so diantus said any negative
solution to equation was automatically
false livets hated them and they didn't
start to be widely used until the mid
19th century which is kind of crazy from
our modern perspective now I think
they're actually more radical than the
irrationals because they changed the
spatial interpretation of the number
line in a very important way so we now
have the origin in the middle of the
line and an infinite extent to either
side it's symmetrical so we can think of
addition and subtraction as translation
in a point in this Infinite Space and
more interestingly we can interpret the
sign flip we get with multiplication by
minus one is a rotation around the
origin by 180 deges some of the
mathematicians here are saying could
also be a reflection and that's true but
today we're going to pretend it's only a
rotation so by so by adding a new kind
of number we get a new kind of space
actually that allows both translation
and a limited form of rotation and the
next big discovery which many of you
have already guessed was complex numbers
so in the 1500s rapael bombelli was
trying to deal with an equation of this
form and the solution that he had gotten
from cardano for this kind of thing was
this this algorithm that you see here in
both maths code and also closure code
and you can see see the problem right
away there's a boundary condition where
P cubed is greater than Q ^2 after which
one needs to take the square root of a
negative number and it returns none
right so it's no good but bombelli
grafted the two components that he was
trying to compare here and Visually
confirmed that they converge and he was
primarily an engineer so he did what any
engineer would do he cluded it yeah so
he used a placeholder and this
placeholder had a special behavior in
these situations and he got this from
cardano who had invented it but said it
was completely useless and he then wrote
a book
bom belly then wrote a book about how to
solve these problems right and and the
textual description you see here is from
that book except the part with i in it
was actually retrofitted in the addition
that I screencapped and although I've
read these books I'm not recommending
any from this period because they
predate anything like modern notation
and the Expedition all looks like this
walls of text with funny drawings but
his method worked which did not stop as
you can imagine everyone from sincerely
hating it and one of the reasons they
hated it which is hinted at at the
bottom there is it seemed to violate the
rules of of mult application it just
didn't make sense and it also looks
arbitrary and magical because they were
still under the influence of the Greeks
in their perspective on numbers now all
of you already know that I stands for
imagin Imaginary but to get a sense of
the vibe Dart coined the term imaginary
number as an insult to the very idea
that such a thing could exist right this
is how people felt about these numbers
but over the next 250 years because they
simplified calculations involving trig
they gained ground and by the early
1800s argand and gaus and vessel all
independently figured out that their
special geometric numbers that encode
rotations in a 2d plane which In
fairness was a concept that did not
exist in bomb Bell's time so we can
forgive him for not
noticing uh some find this easier uh
easier to see if they look at it like
this right this illustration shows that
with each exponentiation I rotates by 90
degrees and notice how this feels kind
of relative to what we saw earlier with
the number line where sign flips sign
flips cause rotations now that we have
two we're kind of able to cut that in
half and there's more going on that I
can't explain to a general audience in
the time I have but in my opinion the
move to complex numbers was the biggest
jump in in the history of math up to
that point to having real geometric
objects things that can represent the
kind of world that we
perceive and uh another important fact
about this is that once you get to them
you can't really keep pretending that
these are numbers in the same sense as
you know the number of goats we're we're
somewhere else now we have escaped the
naturalistic idea of numbers altogether
and I think this is inevitable I think
without it the gymnast part of our
brains would never have a chance so
we're caught up to mid 1800s they were
what you might call electrifying times
right so the study of what we now call
electromagnetism was heating up and
Commercial applications were becoming
very important the internet boom of the
time was the telegraph right it came
into commercial use by 1840 submarine
cables were laid by 1850 how's that for
Progress how's that for building right
so this allowed rapid communication
between continents for the first time to
give you some sense of what that meant
it used to take two and a half months
for a piece of mail to get from London
to Sydney this chart shows you various
ones but we're not going to linger on it
because it's not the main point of this
so this period is where electrical
engineering began it was in the context
of a different kind of information
technology the information of telegraphy
right and our computers descend directly
from the Telegraph and telephone Claud
Shannon's Master thesis which is written
only about 80 years later laid the
blueprint for our digital computers by
applying Boolean algebra to analog
relays in the telephone system and the
people who were working on this stuff at
the time were sort of Matha physicists
right because they they hadn't divided
into two disciplines at this stage all
mathematicians were physicist and vice
versa at least close to that and the big
problem they faced was coming up with a
system for calcul involving 3D space
including rotations this was especially
important for representing the ideas
contained in Maxwell's equations which
we will look at now so this block that
you see on the left there that's what
Maxwell actually wrote down and it's a
lot you know there's a lot of stuff
there and the stuff on the right which
is much more concise and actually much
more clear if you happen to have learned
how to read this particular notation was
created by uh somebody called Gibbs and
another person called heavyside one of
them in the US one of them UK and it's
the system that's taught today and even
if you can't read it you can recognize
how much more concise it is and that it
contains basically the same mathematical
information means we're winning right
we're we're able to communicate more in
less space but the notational system
that I prefer and that I'm kind of
hinting at today captures the same
relationship like this so this this is
actually even more tur but it does
contain all of the relevant information
I cannot explain how in the time I have
today
but but I will link to an explanation
with all the details and for this
audience I want to instead give a very
gental introduction to this notation
which is called geometric
algebra we're going to start with these
Two Fellas so the black and white one is
grasson and the other is Clifford
grasson was a German High School teacher
who invented most of vectric algebra as
a side quest while studying title theory
in his fair time this guy was a genius
unfortunately his writing was as muddy
as his ideas were brilliant so his work
made almost no impact during his
lifetime
Clifford was an English mathematician
born somewhat later and also an
astronomer and he was one of the few to
read and understand grassman's work
which he combined with Hamilton's
querian and he created this system that
he called geometric algebra but that
many modern speakers call Clifford
algebra in his honored unfortunately he
died of tuberculosis at
33 so I suspect we'd have standardized
on his approach if he'd lived long
enough to make the case for it over the
following decades and the uh to talk
about this system We'll add a couple
more objects and operations to our
protocol call so now we have something
like this right multiplication has
trifurcated we have three kinds of
multiplication so the dot product the
wed wedge product and the geometric
product and then we have vectors which
I'm calling here K vectors for reasons
that we will loop back around to in a
couple of minutes so what do we talk
about when we talk about
vectors they're geometric objects
they're not numbers like they're
definitely not numbers but they
represent a combination of a length and
a direction and we'll often call the
length a magnitude which is fancy Latin
for
bigness and we're going to cover this
idea in 2D because that's easier so
we're gonna start with this right so
here you see these two orthogonal basis
vectors so here we have two arrows one
who's positive extent extends to the
right called E1 and one that extends
upward called E2 they're both of unit
length which is to say of magnitude one
note that the written as E1 and E2 not
as X and Y well that's because we as
programmers when we see ourselves giving
individual names to ordered sequences of
similar things we start to think maybe
there should be an array with indices or
something and in that Spirit we're using
these numbered terms so you can add them
together like this right uh and you can
add them adding them together along with
some scalar multiple of each allows you
to create any Arrow of any length
pointing in any angle right it's just
linear combinations of these basis
vectors and you can also subtract them
and subtraction flips the sign of the
subtracted one and this is actually very
similar to what we saw earlier with the
positive and negative number line right
you change the direction of the thing
you learned all this this is all the
same as what you learned in vector
algebra at school the dot product also
pretty much the same as what you learned
at school so so this is a thing that
measures the the co extent of these two
lines through a through distance and if
you use unit vectors that if you
normalize to a length of one of the two
you get the cosine back out and then we
have this guy which is the wedge product
right so this guy is for those of you
with a lot of linear algebra it's a
generalization of another product that
you've already seen called the cross
product and what this guy does is he
returns instead of like the cross
product returns a vector this guy
returns a b Vector so the bi Vector is
this thing you see on the right hand
side here which if a vector is a line
that goes in a direction for some
distance this is an oriented area so
it's just a higher Dimension analog to a
vector and you can see that one Arrow
points to the tail of the other arrow
and then there's a circle in the middle
the circle represents the direction that
you would rotate in order to bring the
head of the second arrow to the tail of
the ladder right and we use the reason I
like these so much compared to other
formulations is that if you Ed by
vectors to provide uh your
representation of torque and angular
momentum in the magnetic field your
computations are actually much more
concise and make more geometric sense
which we'll cover more in just a second
and then the most important one of these
new kinds of multiplication is something
called the geometric product which as
you see here is just taking the dot
product and adding it to the wedge
product now that's kind of weird right
because one of them is returning a
scalar and the other one's returning
this funny bi Vector thing but we've
actually seen this exact same
relationship a few minutes ago and
that's in the complex numbers so so it
it turns out that the imaginary number I
was actually just the unit by Vector all
along and what was once kind of an
algebraic ghost turns out to be a
consequence of the geometry of space now
this is another one where I'll have to
link to the supporting materials but man
the algebraic expansion that proves this
is extremely beautiful now I'm going to
compare this approach to the approach
that we mostly use like if you go and
take Vector there are a lot of matricies
involved and to me the Matrix approach
kind of treats vectors as tuples with
Benefits right it's still it's a series
of numbers and you have to pick the
numbers apart and then you put them into
these matrices and then you grind the
crank on the side and you get you get
the answer but the geometric intuition
that you get from doing that is usually
pretty poor and it takes a lot of time
and work to get students to understand
what these matrices mean in contrast
using geometric algebra you can if you
need a specific rotation uh by an angle
here you do something looks exactly like
what you would do with a complex number
and you can also just rotate by another
bi Vector so simple multiplication you
can say hey I've got a line that points
this way and I want to take the product
of this line and that line and you'll
get a rotation which is kind of amazing
uh as we will see later this this makes
a lot of things way
easier so moving on from there I will
recommend this paper because it can give
you the rigorous treatment that you are
craving right now that I cannot provide
in this short talk so this is called
imaginary numbers are not real it's by
Gull lenb and Duran these are three
physicists who've done loads of work
over the last 20 years to popularize GA
in their writing it it's everything is
very accessible and if you have high
school level maths you can you can plow
through it so we've been talking about
this all in 2D which has has this
particular uh set of entities but one of
the great strengths about this approach
is that as you go up in Dimensions you
keep exactly the same operations and you
have sort of equivalent objects so we're
going to just take a quick look at what
the 3D case might look like which is
this so we talked about how a bi Vector
is what happens when you wedge together
two vectors right then you get this area
but if you wedge together three of those
you get an oriented volume so all the
same operations work the same way in
three dimensions as they worked in two
Dimensions you don't have a lot of new
stuff to learn and this is very
different from how we normally teach
this stuff normally as you go to three
dimensions you learn two or three
different uh pieces of the toolkit that
only ever work in three dimensions like
the cross product but here you just keep
doing things the same way you were doing
them and it continues to work as you go
up and this is why we call them K
vectors because really what you have is
not a vector a bi Vector Tri Vector what
you have is a one vector two Vector
three Vector four Vector however many
Vector that you need and this turns out
to be super useful in physics in fact
variations on geometric algebra have
been reinvented repeatedly over history
because the original notation we had was
insufficient so p and der algebras are
just geometric algebras invented by
physicists to solve physical problems
without even knowing that Clifford's
results had existed and all of this this
huge zoo of geometric Concepts that we
use in technical mathematics are all
representable inside geometric algebra
so instead of having to learn like you
know 10 different things to do your your
basic engineering or physics work you
learn one thing and you keep using
it so what we can say about geometric
algebra is it kind of combines align
areas and volumes now there are other
things we care about in Geometry that
are not there as you can imagine right
there are no planes uh for example there
are no spheres things like that so there
have to be extensions and uh being able
to operate in however many dimensions
you please is great but you kind of need
to add one more thing to get the full
magic of the system and unfortunately it
is the most subtle and hard to explain
thing here so we're going to get extra
extra handwavy now
so that's metrics right so so this is in
our programming language metaphor these
are this is a bit like metaprogramming
where you say I want an algebra and I
want this many dimensions of the AL
algebra to square to minus one like B
vectors do but I also want some that's
squared to either one or zero the more
mathematically sophisticated among you
be saying oh yeah so if you need a
hyperbolic space you could have this and
so on and that's exactly it you can you
can then represent more different kinds
of spaces this way and once you do that
you can Source a up
a vast variety of the tools that we use
for technical mathematics as these
little metric versions of geometric
algebra so here are some examples now
this is not in any sense a complete list
but these are some very popular tools
that you can get in this way uh and I'll
I'll shout out a couple in particular
right so the um macowski SpaceTime is
super cool for doing physics and a lot
of people are using it for that purpose
and if you look at the conformal
geometric algebra the last one on the
list this one is neat because it has his
basic objects things like spheres and so
if you want a circle you look at the
intersection of two spheres and the part
where they meet is a circle and there
are situations where that is pretty
great but for me the one that is most
interesting uh for the things I do day
in and day out is projective geometric
algebra which I use a lot for computer
Graphics applications and for that I'm
going to recommend this paper and I'll
say that that this line of research
really kicked off in 2000 in the context
of Robotics when people were looking for
better ways to uh to handle the geometry
of the world inside of a a situated
agent and there was a fellow called
zelig who wrote a really nice paper I
will link to it and that was followed up
by theoretical work by a fellow called
Charles Gun uh but because of the
background of this audience I think the
best paper for you if you're interested
in this part is this one by dor and
deenik uh and these same people have
many Fantastic video presentations on
YouTube you can find great stuff about
this that will go in depth and Deen in
particular is a tireless Advocate who
has built a fantastic JavaScript
playground for this stuff called ganja
uh but in the meantime time we're going
to do a little bit of ill-advised live
coding right
[Applause]
so okay so we have our friend emac here
and we have a little
box you'll notice it's closure code
sorry for the non list people there's a
JavaScript version of this I I will link
to as well which you know if you need
infix it has it for you uh
so so this is one of those metric things
where I'm I'm declaring this uh this
certain algebra of these
dimensions and and this metric and I'm
not going to explain what that means at
the moment these are kind of throwaway
things that are building that box by
knowing how to make uh vertices and
edges you got some starter state for a
couple of things and then this this
function here is uh the entire physics
engine and and I want to make clear that
what I'm about to show you there's
nothing underneath right this is just uh
this is just a mathematics library that
I'm using to do this so I'm going to
come down here and I'm going to
uncomment this line and and our little
friend the
Box will start to bounce around as soon
as I can get my mouse over there all
right right so the reason we can do this
with only like three lines of code to
account for Gravity hooks law and a
damping function is because the entities
that we're using in this context know
about both direction and rotation and
magnitude all at the same time so this
is actually pretty cool now those of you
who do a lot of physics or Graphics
programming probably think well you know
2D it's not that big a deal right I mean
so what happens if we change this to a
three and we come over here and we do it
again oh it's it's a cube now so you'll
note a couple of things here I didn't
change a single line of code other than
the dimensionality that's pretty boss
actually normally you'd have to do a
bunch of stuff like if you're a graphics
programmer you can clap it's okay now
I'm going to
change but you know what if we wanted
four dimensions how about a tesseract on
a string right like that's pretty
[Applause]
cool so I I'll post later I'll post a
blog post or something where I go into
line by line what's happening here but
it it is pretty amazing and the code
because it's in this nice lispy language
is basically onetoone with the
mathematics that we would otherwise use
so uh oh I can't get back to my notes
I'm trapped in live coding forever let's
see which I guess isn't the worst thing
that could happen there we go all right
so
all right so hopefully this tiny taste
has been enough to attract your interest
we're pretty much out of time but before
you go I need to mention David Hennis
that's this joyful looking man here in
the 1960s he started work on a research
program aimed at refactoring the
notation used for technical mathematics
using geometric algebra and my first
exposure to these ideas was in an 80s
paper of his that used geometric algebra
to explore theong as a lens on
understanding direct theory of electrons
it was mind-blowing it blew my mind and
after after spending some time with it I
came to agree with this quote from David
Estus right so this is a way that we we
can just move everything into a single
formalism and simplify everything that
we're doing this is a chance we have to
refactor things in a way that could
reduce by maybe two or three years the
time it takes to educate a young
physicist and in so doing make more
advanced topics accessible to many more
people this would I believe result in
real progress in The Sciences which is
why I care enough to bring this to your
attention today and if this talk
inspires you to read only one paper I
would ask you to read David EST Stan's
2002 or metal lecture in which he makes
this case very very well and I'll close
with this quote from hen's old Professor
Richard fan and a few thank yous uh
first I'd like to thank Alex Miller for
his tireless efforts organizing one of
the best technology conferences in the
world for all these years can we
yeah and I'd like to thank the
organizers of papers we love Zan shout
out for for inviting me
I'd like to thank my friend heish Todd
for telling me over lunch in Berlin a
few years ago that an active Community
had formed around geometric algebra thus
renewing my hopes for the future I'd
like to give thanks to my colleagues at
next journal for tolerating my eent
excentricities and supporting my work
including the creation of this talk and
lastly and of course thanks to all of
you for
[Applause]
listening